what's happening my well-read Ballas
this week we can read tape up in that
ass with the trowel by Franz Kafka
banker man Joseph K just turned 30 and
nearly chillin at the crib waiting for
some grub Saul good chilled knock knock
man I better be my food huh
who is this soup rollin up on my spot
apparently this tight ass dude
representing the law and Land ankh a
baby wrong you under arrest son what
would I even do but this Katniss boy
keep their mouth shut and don't give
them no reason
so these haters take came next door will
they be a ghetto red course that's going
down the top dog inspector start running
his mouth about how K is is some deep
but he still don't say why what the hell
K walks for now but this man show is
Harrell ain't over not even close
later word come from the law that K
gotta bust ass to court without telling
them one time on the room number where
all this is going down I have to
sweating his nuts off trying to find
this place
he finally get to an attic in a good-ass
building with a judge like boy you are
our five minutes late so k step up and
rock the mic saying that this system is
straight crooked but nobody give a damn
about what he got to say later k baby on
the grind when he hears something funky
oh no people better not be getting
freaky in my bank what the hell is going
on apparently the suits who arrested
can't get whupped on cuz k ratted on
them in court for trying to boost his
swag can't feel mad guilty and want to
put a stop to this mess
but the whipping man ain't backing down
for nothing brother got to do what he
got to do then case huncle drop in and
be all like yo you taking this case
seriously boy cuz your ass is on the
line so Ches argyll introduces them to a
lawyer named Paul
and is bangin nurse Lenny yeah but hold
is completely [ __ ] useless brother
Lee ain't got a clue
YK got the law all up in his ass and
there ain't nothing he can do and if dad
ain't cryin ufff the chief clerk of the
court was just chilling in the shadows
the whole damn time just diddling
himself it's time go by I can't keep
hitting up his lawyer this shyster never
do Jack's
no kid bugger so hard about the case
that a customer roll of that work and be
like sprung you should talk to my home
he's hit a rally he work up at the court
so he knows what's what so k hit up to
the rally who are like Real Talk man
you're basically they ain't never gonna
call you innocent so you might as well
just bend over now okay thinking he
gotta shake his punk ass lawyer so he
swang over to the office when his
raggedy dude named Block B chillin
apparently black was ballin as a
businessman back in the day but since
the law came down on his ass like they
do it okay he spent all this Chado
illegal defense and now he all cashed
out on the struggle when k try to break
it off with hold the lawyer like not so
fast bro you walk away and you gonna be
nothing but a dog like block then the
bank tell Kay you got to show one of
their big dog clients around town dudes
say he won a peep game at the Cathedral
but when he had no show cages checked
the spot out for himself before he
bought the lead the priests hollering
tell him he worked for the courtroom too
he tried to explain Kay's bunker a
situation with a fable but it don't mean
a damn thing the king a year goes by
since all this craziness first went down
on the night before a case 31st birthday
two suits arrived at his crib this time
though k ain't even trippin bout it
matter of fact can take the lead and
they head to a quarry when k put his
head on a boat and one of the suits
shanks him right in the heart
twist damn Kay's last words before you
take that long dirt nap like a dog
[Music]
man this trap Joey Kay living in show
one crooked ass place brother ain't got
no rights no voice and no options the
Lord got his nuts in a vise and there
ain't nothing he can do about it but the
scariest thing koepcke preaching is that
it don't take a hard-ass thug putting a
Glock to your dome in order to take away
your dignity and freedom my blood up in
this hood homies are broken down by a
slow orderly system that's designed to
keep people in check even though it's
frontin like it's all righteous like
check this even though Kay never do any
time behind bars and then cuz things are
good truth is they don't need to throw
Kay in a slammer
since every day in this society is like
living in the pen anyway you have
misunderstood me you are under arrest
certainly but that not need hinder you
from going about your business nor will
you be prevented from leading your
ordinary life yeah the man all the way
up Kay's ass for this whole damn book
but just cuz they the law show is hell
don't mean they preach injustice matter
of fact the law could be the most unjust
thing you ever seen but when you got
people following it proudly and enforce
it just cuz it's their job the fact that
it ain't just don't even matter the law
supposed to protect your rights but I've
been here there's nothing more than a
weapon to keep you scared and in your
place our officials never go hunting for
crime in the populous but as the law
decrees are drawn toward the guilty it
must then send out US waters that is the
law and how could that be a mistake in
that it's like a money living in a
totalitarian nightmare
matter of fact Kafka style game making
this whole novel feel like a tripped out
dream for example when K up in court he
tried to chunk deuces out of there but
the magistrate just pop up in front of
the door like he teleporting or
something the hell I wouldn't mean with
his lawyer the chief clerk just appear
in the corner of the room like he's been
creepin in the shadows this whole time
the hell is he doing over there thing is
though a few years after Kafka was
running the lit game
this wasn't a dream
no more it ended up coming true this
whole society sounded like some kind of
totalitarian prophecy all the fear and
isolation these wack-ass places use well
hello similar to joseon Ches society
straight down to the threads the police
war and the most fun thing about it
ain't the way they can break your bones
but the way they can break your spirit
and that's exactly the point
evil ain't gotta be some mustache
twirling player doing gangsters
sometimes the gnarliest evil is a bar
there's bureaucracy that wears us down
day by day with Bush brights and corrupt
systems that make your life such a
living hell that you don't even know
what you fighting for no more a society
like that can to humanize you so much
that you just want to be taken out back
and put down bail like a dog yo thanks
for kicking it with your boy man catch
y'all next time
[Music]
you